hello guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm
Taylor Bradley we gonna check out the
official trailer number one for Pride
and Prejudice and Zombies based on the
Jane Eyre novel the original this is the
original manuscript that she had for it
is it Jane Eyre what's her name again
Jane Austen Austin who's Jane Eyre I
don't know I don't know Jane Austen I
thought so
yeah whose genius I don't know who is
Jane Eyre tell me who Jane Eyre is I
never read Jane Austen thing before
that's pg-13 some of the most scary
movies are pg-13 don't even go there
zombie movie yeah
it began with the Black Plague within
weeks the dead began to rise hunting the
human flesh
now the few of us that are left have
only one way to survive we must bring
the fight today I've been training for
this my whole life
the fairest wifely choices to be right
here in this room my daughters
whoa that's a cool shot that was cool
nice
I do not know which okay how you feel if
you look pretty good I feel pretty good
the entire time I was thinking okay a
ton of like thirteen-year-old girls are
gonna have found our new favorite movie
then I was thinking but do a lot of
thirteen-year-old girls who read Pride
and Prejudice like things with zombies
well the Pride and Prejudice and Zombies
book was pretty big it was really big
but I don't know what the demographic
was so I'm really sure used to figure
out what the demographic for this movie
is gonna be because I feel like it'll be
the same people as the book but well
there's no we're really trying to appeal
to like a teen audience right now right
you really get that vibe that's who sees
movies that's that's pg-13 well when
this could have been a rated R flick oh
yeah but they wanted to stay within the
younger demographic because I think that
might have been who was reading the
books see I'm not sure if it'll like it
still looks like it could be raw in a
lot of ways yeah with the zombie
violence
I mean after like a lot of zombie films
I feel like cutting back on the violence
might be a little distracting it could
be distracting but it could also be a
breath of fresh air because a lot of
zombie films rely so heavily on the gore
and on the violence that it's like if
they turn and kind of make it more of a
storyline would you seems like they're
trying to do that could be a whole
different genre of zombie flicks which
could potentially reeve I like
revitalize the whole genre sure sure
that's true I know this is just the
trailer for it and they're really
advertising the action a lot in this
yeah but it's based on a book yeah so I
know that the book is way more than just
action scenes oh yeah because it has to
be right otherwise it would be like
you're reading choreography the whole
time you know this can be difficult so I
never read the story I don't know what
all the specific changes that happen
from the zombies right I didn't read the
Pride and Prejudice and Zombies but I've
read most of Pride and Prejudice so I'm
gonna be it's gonna be interesting to
see what changes are made to make it
yeah I like what they're capturing so
far some of those scenes look great I
really did dig that one shot reace
cutting the zombie off yeah stomps his
head that was a great shot the chick
looks [ __ ] badass oh yeah
and like a bunch they're making what
time period is this a place in like the
1800s or late late 1700s early and I
like seeing like these very female lady
characters especially at that time time
period when they're all about like
working in the kitchen you don't think
and it's like they even mentioned that
throughout it yeah so I can't use like
they're like kind of training them like
they're spies in a way right I didn't
like but they're also very good at
fighting
yeah so it's like you got it you got to
have the etiquette see down you gotta be
able to dance gonna be able to sing
because it's all a part of the illusion
of being able to fight as well you know
I like that's awesome that's and it's
cool to see like they're taking 1800s
kind of chicks and then they're making
them like very authorized and yeah with
the weapons and then Oakland that was a
cool accent where they all like flicked
up their dresses yeah yeah it looks
pretty badass
I would like Veronica to wear that for
me one day you should get her that
costume I should get her that costume
she could wear for me and oh my god oh
we're still filming I miss having sex
that's the saddest thing ever
oh yeah whatever here
what well we might remember something
mrs. obvious one thing I really want
there to is you know I've seen like the
Pride and Prejudice movie yeah which is
the closest I'll get to reading the book
yeah and I didn't see those miniseries
when I saw the Keira Knightley one I
like the idea of still honoring that
story and that tone while infusing
zombies into it and this seems like a
really hard film to advertise yes
because it's like you want the Jane
Austen fans who to also be appeal to it
right and you want people who were
seeing it because yeah it's so different
like two very different demographics and
they're trying to appeal to both and so
it's very hard film the market but I'm
hoping when I'm watching the actual
actual execution of it that there is a
lot of the Jane Austen vibe in there
rather than just sacrificing it for a
zombie picture yeah I like that use the
word execution of it I felt like that
was a really good I know I'm working at
because of the zombies yes yes yeah I'm
working on meanwhile witty instead of
relying on dick jokes oh that's really
good I'm a little hard no you're doing
great ha ha ha
we were like two seconds in and I was
like yay and then anyway guys if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe
today and become a let's look at some
movie titles then maybe I can come up
with something become a reject Tom be
today oh that's stupid
a rejecter eater subscribe today and
become a reject an IRA Soros reject a
Soros it's like a cold sore you can
check out Taylor Bradley's channel where
she has a web series coming up there in
post right now subscribe today
that way you can get notified when it's
out funny you could follow us on faith
sorry
so much
Keitha burro Lee I would like a
shout-out on my youtube name is K dude B
squared okay you want a shout-out you're
supposed to say something interesting if
you want to show hehe got a shout-out
even though he didn't say anything
interesting so really I thank you oh
here's a black sub I want to like your
glasses they're really cool I like the
aviator look yeah it's great
I want more black subscribers though I'm
trying to really appeal to the I feel
like I feel like the target market is
the black market for me okay not the
black mark like the dangerous mark I
mean like the african-american or II
just I don't think that's Pleasant there
like some kind of yeah there's other
kinds of black out there I only know
African American keith Oboro lee is
actually a position that a lot of black
people like to do the position is when
you actually put your penis and then you
pull it out and then she vomits and
poops at the same time it is is
something pretty [ __ ] insane I have
nothing to do with this well nothing
that is how it goes now you've learned
what the ketha berola is get Keith OH
today